ce mot
[Applaudissements]
ganesh d'europe le net est une véritable
bête de scène est une des plus grandes
voix de l'histoire du rock
[Musique]
janis joplin est né dans le texas des
années 1940
humiliés et rejeté par ses camarades de
classe qui se moque de son physique elle
se réfugie très jeune dans le blues de
bessie smith et de big mamma quentin le
besoin d'être aimé
malgré tout le système c'était
transcendante et gentil est alimenté par
sow était tout crier leurs normes
de l'amour janis joplin en a reçu dans
les années 60 au point de devenir l'un
des symboles phare de la contre-culture
encore aujourd'hui sa légende inspire la
chanteuse de who use
et avec un qui est arrivé et les femmes
ont eu le droit de devenir quelqu'un
ils ont le droit d'être plus apte que
ligue a que sa place à les heures à
l'heure alors pas demander à personne de
permission a s'est pas excusé non plus
angel forrest est en tournée virtuelle
au canada a aussi janis joplin dans la
peau depuis près de trente ans pour moi
je n'oublie jamais de moi c'est ce que
halo mais moi je chante il y en a comme
toi aux quatre que j'ai fait pendant les
shows l'ascension de janis joplin a été
fulgurante
sa chute a été encore plus elle est
décédée le 4 octobre 1970 à l'âge de 27
ans d'une surdose d'héroïne et l'été sur
le point de terminer l'enregistrement de
son quatrième disque comme un
chef-d'oeuvre sortie après son décès et
donc qu'elle n'a jamais pu entendre ici
louis philippe ouimet radio canada bon
rien
[Musique]